ottawa's children's hospital is facing a
double whammy staff are out sick with
omicron and two-thirds of kids coming
into hcr have coveted symptoms
so we're seeing specifically with this
wave is now increased emergency volumes
levels that we're typically seeing at
the height of viral seasons out of more
than 53 000 cases of cobit reported
between april 10th and 16th countrywide
over 3 000 almost 6 percent were kids
under 11. delays in data entry and
testing restrictions mean the actual
number is likely higher and recently
removed health measures such as masking
in schools and day cares aren't helping
we are in an enumerable way where
kids are getting infected like crazy
there's no more restriction to try to
protect them mother julie la joie has
seen her children through two bouts of
covid while waiting on health canada to
authorize a pediatric vaccine for kids
under five and the regulator says it has
yet to receive any submissions from drug
makers the majority of kids have milder
illness but there are some kids that can
have significant illness and some kids
have long-term illness in march modern
reported its two-dose kid cove vaccine
was around 40 percent effective at
preventing infection the company says it
plans to file for emergency use
authorization in the u.s by the end of
this week but experts believe the fda
will want to see data on three doses
what they're looking for is to make sure
that if
this vaccine is indeed given to children
does it still work against the type of
coronavirus that's currently in
circulation pfizer says the results of
its three dose clinical trials will be
ready in the coming weeks what it
couldn't say was when it plans to ask
health canada to approve the shot for
parents the weight is infuriating that
vaccine is not there and now there's no
kind of protection
community level protection that can help
to protect them so
parents feel isolated for sure left to
fend for themselves and take precautions
on their own jamie rocker global news
toronto